ظروف مختلفه تحيط باطلاق الموسم الخامس
لمسلسل ذكراون الانجليزيه هذا العام فهو
الاول منذ وفاه الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
والاول منذ اعتلاء الملك تشارلز العرش
البريطاني ما يعني انا دور دومني كويس
ياتي في وقت حساس بنسبه لملك ما زال يستقر
في منصبه ويحاول كسب قلوب بريطانيينك
ومن المتوقع ان يجذب الموسم قاعده
جماهيريه عربيه حيث يضم طاقم التمثيل هذا
العام ممثلين عربا لتشديد دور محمد الفايد
وابنه دود الفايد
[موسيقى]
يعني
نقوم باداء هذه الشخصيات العملاقه كان في
مشاهد احنا
بنصورها واحنا احنا بقينا المشاهدين العرب
بنتفرج يالهوي ده احنا بنعمل ده في حاجه
جميله
نافع عند السعاده
الفتره المطربه من حياه الاميره ديانا
والمقابله التي صعدت العالم وزعزعت العرش
البريطاني عام
1995 قبل عامين من وفاتها الماء سوريه
ما هذه السجاده الحمراء مشى ابطال المسلسل
الاكثر اثاره للجدل في بريطانيا منذ ست
سنوات والذي على وشك ان يصبح اكثر اثاره
مع بدء الموسم الخامس الذي يروي الفصل
الاكثر توتررا في حياه العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه فيما اصوات المنتقدين لايقاف
المسلسل تتعلى
ويواجه المسلسل عاصفه من الانتقادات من
قبل الوسطين الفني والسياسي التي تتهم
القائمين عليه بسرد ما تصفه بالاكاذيب
خلال مرحله صعبه شهدتها لعائله الملكيه
حيث يكشف المسلسل ان الامير تشارلز حاول
اقناع الملكه بالتنازل عن العرش كما يتم
ترشيد المشاكل بين تشارلز وزوجته كانت
الاميره ديانا بشكل يعتبره البعض انه يصور
الملك بشكل سلبي